with this message we convince
We started talking about things
important for ordinary Poles
who are not interested in ideologies
but who fear for their existence
There's nothing wrong with that.
We want to convince them with material arguments.
Confederation is the best policy option.
because it is the truth
I absolutely do not believe and I will never believe
and there is no such strength
which will force me to accept
It is impossible to simplify taxes.
that you can't change all these things
because we only have the right solutions
and we want to connect
Ideality with a reasonable economic program
State and we do it.
I can't believe it has to be like this.
The tax office is the enemy of the taxpayer.
that officials
Treasures occupied
Provocation against the taxpayer
to chase children for it
They sell lemonade.
to chase the old woman for it
that they sell radish
We can do everything
It shows our faith in our own strength.
If we did not have this faith
We would not form our partners
Alone against all
15.
October is National Table Turning Day
Confederation We Can Do Anything
they are already afraid of it
They are afraid because we know.
that we can do everything